story hey what's up my name is samuel
leeds and in this video i'm going to
introduce you to a guy called lawrence
who got made redundant from thomas cook
last year
he sold all his stocks everything he had
and put it into property
he's now completely financially free
became financially free from
one deal alone that he bought from
auction he's going to share the exact
story
a to z step by step how he became
financially free in property so that you
can do the same too
stay tuned lawrence so good to have you
in my home thank you
i needed to get you down here because
you came on the crash course when did
you come to class
it was june last year in excel all right
talk to me what happened what have you
done since
you've become financially independent
yeah incredibly remarkable story
so i want to know tell me everything
gosh i mean it's been such a
roller coaster so i've gone basically
from zero to
pretty much 14 properties um
went on the crash course well first of
all i lost so i worked in sales
recruitment for
10 years lost my job when thomas cook
went under
and i went home went on youtube and i
was all right financial freedom
strategies what do i do saw
your um financial freedom challenge and
i was like this guy's just done in one
week
in like i think it was wolverhampton or
wherever it was um what i've been trying
to do for 10 years so i need to go
check this guy out see what he's done i
went on the course
and i probably learned more in i'd say
three
hours at your course than i did at three
years at uni and 30k of student debt um
and then i literally just took
everything i learned and rather than i
guess just keep learning i just threw
myself into it
um i don't think where to start i went i
went to blackpool
and because it was just probably so
cheap and originally went up there to
try and do like a rent to rent strategy
and then i saw a block of flats for sale
for um 170 000 pounds it was 10 flats
and i just couldn't believe how
cheap it was and as soon as i saw it i
got my calculator out got my spreadsheet
uh you know went through everything we
learned on the course in terms of
you know how to figure out what your
cash flow what your roi is and i was
like this is
unbelievable like if i can make this
work you'll be making thousands and
thousands of pounds every month
um how would it be making thousands and
thousands because most people might
think
okay block of 10 flats you might rent
out the average flat four
in blackpool 350 400 quid
how's that going to make thousands of
pounds but obviously what you did was
creative
yeah talk to me about what you did so
everything we did was all on service
accommodation yeah um so obviously you
can charge
50 60 70 80 pounds a night in some
circumstances
um so all you need to do is have one
room for 50 pounds a night for say
20 days and you've already made a
thousand pounds of one little flat yeah
so i just thought you know if i get 10
of these flats up and running at
potentially 50 pounds a day
um and the location was perfect um i was
yeah i just went for it basically and so
you bought a block of flats
in blackpool cheapest chips yeah and
how's it going it's amazing so last
month the revenue was 6 000 pounds
and that's in the middle of a pandemic
yeah you know we're going to partner
with a lot of the local
engineers and theaters down the line as
well make sure it's fully
booked but yeah and that's also two of
them aren't even ready all right
two of them aren't even finished yet or
renovated so in a pandemic with two of
them still under renovation
yeah you just made six thousand pound
last month like in august
which is just incredible um so
you must be pinching yourself yeah i
mean it's still crazy it's been such a
roller coaster as well and especially
when i first bought it
bit at auction then a week later the
pandemic hit and i was like oh god what
have i done
yeah yeah um but i just spoke with my
management agent
um everything about the property they
said was just perfect it worked really
well and so i just had to trust the
process
go with it and yeah yeah it's paying off
and you're like the
you i've seen you trolling the trolls on
youtube
yeah talk to me about that because it's
sorry i just find it so funny because
obviously they have a go at you for like
the
for the course and how much it costs et
cetera but i'm i've just i just learned
so much off a free course that has
completely changed my life
so um yeah if i see them say something
i'm just
they're just making excuses and jealous
and bitter because yeah
it can happen yeah and that's not the
only project you've done you've got
you've got the block of 10 flats but
you've also
um i mean did you get the blood you've
got the blockers just now the crash cost
was almost a year ago yeah so talk to me
about your first
and one of the very first property that
you bought
and i also want to know how you found it
how you chose the
area i want the facts i want you to all
everything you learned from the crash
course you implemented
i now want the recent not the recycled
version but the tried
tested got the t-shirt now what you've
done with it so
talk to me about leave the crash course
what's the very first thing that you did
well the first thing i did well i just
obviously lost my job so i needed to try
and get a mortgage in principle as well
but then i remember what you said at the
course it's like
if you're gonna buy an actual a cash
flow producing asset you you don't need
to have a full time income yourself you
know correct
it's based off the asset itself so um i
spent the first couple of months just
talking to mortgage brokers i think i
got laughed out of all the banks at the
start
and then there's but if you've got a
good opportunity you can always find a
lender
um so yeah got my mortgage in principle
and then
i went i just i booked about 40 viewings
in one week in liverpool and nottingham
i just went all over
um and i was just looking for what
places are going to potentially grow the
next and i think i chose on liverpool
um yeah i just went through the crash
course booklet
obviously all of the all of the numbers
the roi
um uh open rent obviously i made sure i
checked what kind of the local houses
next door
uh we're renting out for and just put it
all into the spreadsheet everything i
learned on the course
and i just trusted the maths basically
and that's that's all i did i just made
sure it worked
so you bought so okay so you so so
another crash course
because we actually do it at the crash
course don't worry yeah this is the
thing so i
so i've been investing kind of in in
stocks and dividend payments for about
eight nine years but they pay like three
four five percent really low
cash flow and then i remember being at
the course and after about three hours
when you calculate at the course you can
actually make you know
20 25 roi on your money back i was like
okay well if i just go home sell my
stocks and put it all into property
i can five times my cash flow and i'll
be financially free within a year
so i got super excited went straight to
liverpool and i just yeah i
i've averaged out about 17 roi over the
two to two houses very very good and i
mean the title of this video by the way
should be
why i sold my stocks and invested in
property instead
yeah talk to me about the difference
between property and stocks and you've
done both now yeah
about the difference i mean i think
stocks is definitely kind of the
the lazy way it's a hassle-free
but you don't get the same income you
don't get the same capital growth
um and you don't i mean at the end of
the day you're at the mercy of the stock
market
yeah whereas you know i'm at the mercy
of if i want to hold on to my house i
don't have to sell it's not going to go
down
um i think you just have so much more
control on owning the property yourself
and then you can be so much more um
flexible with the financing on it as
well
and i think that's the biggest thing
that i've learned is how is raising
finance
as long as you've got good opportunity
like you can do so many different things
with it like the blackpool flats i
potentially could have actually bought
that entire block for 175 000 that six
thousand pounds a month income
all for free because i bought it on a
bridging loan
at such a low discount when i refinance
it at the higher amount at what it's
worth
i'm basically pulling out all my money
on a mortgage and then i wouldn't have
literally put up
i would have just got all my money back
out so it's just bizarre the fact that
yeah yeah i still can't believe like a
year's gone by and i'm
making like six seven thousand pounds a
month just
yeah literally i just went in and just
did it yeah so
so um talk to me about that first
liverpool property then yeah
like how did you find it what did you
say to the agents like what happened
uh i just you know i just tried to book
in as
many viewings as possible and just i
just because i i've never done a viewing
before either
yeah and but i was so excited and
desperate to just buy somewhere i'm
i just went to all the local estate
agents in um i found out spoke with them
found out what they thought were the
best postcodes
i spoke with a lot of the different taxi
drivers as well and they're like don't
go down that road
um there was a house i thought about
buying at one point as well but then i
spoke with the next door neighbor and
there were
no loads of gangs around here i wouldn't
do it well where was that in liverpool
oh
it was l4 it was anfield somewhere okay
yeah yeah because i think that's really
important as well sometimes people say
to me they say
where's the best investment area and for
me it's like
i can't give you a city because even in
liverpool you've got two properties
yeah yeah it depends on where you are
like i said liverpool is great but
one street could be awesome a quarter of
a mile down the road another street
could be
could be really good so you've got to do
so much due diligence so what diligence
did you do
before you started investing in
liverpool because you're not from
liverpool right
no no no you're from uh southeast london
right so in terms of like crime rates
what the agents are saying rentability
we talk about the crash about do you
remember
the risks yes yeah yeah i remember doing
that right so
how did you how did you risk it with a
stock you're not gonna you're not gonna
buy a stock and then end up
having oh that's a nightmare stock
there's a property that can happen
so how did you de-risk it and how did
you make sure that you weren't buying
an absolute dirt in a terrible area
that's a good question um
i mean i probably just looked at the
main thing i was looking at was open
rent and just really
probably i'd say most of the um due
diligence i did was probably more on the
ground actually talking to the local
estate agents what the rental demands
were for the local areas
yeah because if i'm gonna buy a house
the most important thing is that it
rents out well
yeah so i went around and i just spoke
with as many of the estate agents as
possible
obviously spareroom.com make sure you
see there's high demand in that area as
well
um just mouse click check obviously the
house prices you can kind of see as well
that everything follows
like london birmingham manchester yeah
liverpool and then burnley hopefully
next blackpool as well but
um yeah there's just so many articles
and i've met so many other investors as
well that are boring
most people when they buy though i find
they just go with their feelings with
their gut
and oh do i like the area how does it
feel but actually
this is a this is a process isn't it
yeah you've got to you've got to check
the right website
speak to the right agents ask the right
questions um
so the first house in liverpool you
bought it for how much uh 90 000.
okay and what was what did did you get a
discount was that the ask
i got it it was i got it five grand
under the asking price
but it was also ten thousand pounds
under what the person bought it for
two years ago okay and that was because
they're having a divorce so
technically made ten thousand pounds in
just buying it yeah um
and you're renting that out for five
nine 590
mortgage payments about 150. so you're
making a 200 quid a month
making about three five five on it yeah
and if you add that up over the year
you're talking just showing four
thousand pounds yeah
how much did you put down as a deposit
it's about i think it was about 25 000.
it was something around that amount it
was
25 um but overall it was 17
roi is what i've got in there that's a
spreadsheet which and i i always say
if it's less than 15 don't buy it yeah
20 percent's the target well i aimed for
20 as well but then there was always
little things that kept
coming up which i didn't plan for and
elevated or a new boiler or a new
sensor or something so how who are the
tenants how's that going uh yeah tennis
really good ones uh surveyor
um yeah no problems at all um the other
tenant i've got
she's got a guarantee garen guarantor
sorry yeah
um she's actually she's actually on
housing benefit as well she's a lovely
lady she's got kids
just got really good feeling um and yeah
no problems at all so at the moment if
she's on housing benefits it's probably
a good thing because the rent is a bit
more guaranteed
yeah if the council are paying it yeah
then if then if she was
if she was working on cure blame well
this is what i thought about my um
about the flats in blackpool as well i
calculated obviously what i could get on
sa but even
at that price even if i just rent them
out to like the local
council or i'll help the homeless like
you'd still
cover any mortgage payment on 175 000
pounds for 10 flats it must have been
nerve-racking they're buying it from
auction
oh i was yeah i mean do you
do you get nervous are you a nervous
investor are you confident not normally
i'm probably
nervous you were nervous about getting
really nervous about coming here yeah
but you you've been in the amazon jungle
yeah yeah i lived in like the amazon
jungle and been around jaguars and
anaconda stuff doesn't scare me at all
but
put me on camera yeah but some people i
have to drag people sometimes to come on
the show because
but i always i always teach you here at
the crash course if you're not
uncomfortable
you're not growing so get comfortable
getting uncomfortable
um but like what happened at the auction
did you physically go
no it's all online yeah as well but i
was bouncing back and forth
um it was i think it was patterson's i
was using
yeah um but i it was just yeah it was
just so nerve-wracking i mean as soon as
i did it
um i just i yeah
i don't really know what to say when
they said that you were the highest
bidder you won
did you feel sick did you feel i felt
sick i i generally felt like what the
hell have i done why
because i i originally went up there to
not even spend any money i was just
gonna try and maybe find like a rent to
rent
and network around and i came back home
and i was like talking to my dad and i
said dad i've just bought 10
flats and you hooked up with one of our
academy members
well i i went up there and i just tried
to network and i tried to find out who
was selling deals up there
and there was a lady called becky butler
who i think was one of your academy
members as well
she's been on winners wednesday she has
yeah she's making 10 grand a month from
her
service to combination yeah in blackpool
as well that's true yeah so you came to
me for that what happened
uh so yeah i've got rent to rent that
i've got of her as well right
um so that's going well i mean been bit
hit hard by the pandemic
um but it was just through meeting her
she introduced me to my new management
agent who's called lisa holmes who runs
the
uh blackpool accommodation uh facebook
page so make sure you follow me yeah
i'll check that out i'll leave a link
um and yeah they've been great so it's
just just through networking and it's a
small world when you get into property
as well and everyone's just so lovely
as well like one thing i found is i
always thought oh a lot
people in property they'll be too busy
they won't want to help like but
yeah they they generally really want to
help
you just ask yeah anyone will meet you
for a coffee pretty much it's an
industry
i found property is an industry where
everybody wants
everybody to win generally speaking not
always sometimes human nature is wanting
people to lose because they feel that
they're going to win by you losing but i
mean i'm certainly trying to break that
i know certainly in my world
in property the whole mantra is your
success is our success and it's about
helping people so i'm really glad to
hear that
academy members helped you out with what
you're doing becky and that's a shout
out to her
what been the biggest lessons then from
the whole over the years it's been like
a roller coaster it's been crazy what's
been the biggest lessons
i think it's just figuring out that
there's always a way
as long as the opportunity is good
there's always a way to make it happen
you can always find
you know you'll always be able to find a
lender you're you'll always be able to
do something with that property
yeah and i think it's just making sure
you trust in the numbers
as well and just doing your due
diligence and just trying to take into
account everything
that could go wrong this is a people
business and a numbers business
so i think if you need to be able to
talk to people negotiate but also crunch
the numbers i think that's
vitally important i think yeah
definitely trusting you've got i mean i
went up there and i just made friends
with
um a lot of the estate agents and my
management agency and i got them to
actually come to the viewings
my management agent come to the viewing
with me and they said that they've
you know worked in the area for got 10
years or so and they were like this this
street is perfect for the tourism
it will rent out really well spoke with
the next door neighbors of the hotel as
well and they were like yeah it's
perfect it sells out every year
um and that was all i really needed
because i pull it put it in the
calculator in the spreadsheet and
i was just convinced that it would work
and yeah here we are so
are you planning on going back to stocks
as an investment no no definitely not
everything yeah stick to property
property all i want to do now is
buy refurb and refinance yes because if
i can get a good
finance package um i would have
technically just bought this whole block
of 10 flats for free
which i just find crazy so i liked what
you said as well about how
the lenders uh i mean i see this at the
crash course
but if the house is good if it's a good
investment
you're gonna get lending on it because
sometimes people worry they say things
like i can't get lending i can't get
it's like it's all about you yeah it's
it's about the investments that you can
find
if you learn to find good deals
everything else will follow yeah
do you believe that 100 i mean i spoke
to probably about 10 different brokers
as well at the start and half of them
all said just no like there's no chance
you can't do this
and then you know fast forward six
months later they're emailing me being
like who did you use by the way who
who was your lender and yeah they're
interested yeah because you didn't have
a job
yeah it's crazy how did you get to the
position where you didn't have a job
just because thomas cook went under okay
so yeah so you lost your job
they weren't burst and you thought
forget this um but i bet now you're
making more money than you were at
thomas got oh 100
a lot more and and it was i just
remember being at the crash course
um uh and as soon as i realized
the roi that you could get i i pretty
much wanted to leave after three hours i
don't need to say i just need to go and
just get this done yeah
um which is why i'm so kind of
passionate about
the course and everything i learned
there as well i really appreciate that
what would you say to someone that was
that was
considering going maybe they've seen
some of the bad reviews maybe they've
seen some of the
the neckheads on on youtube comments
yeah what would your advice be just go
on the crash course you have to go to
like
you can't i can't explain how much value
you get from that um it's easily worth
more than the 30
000 pounds that you can ever spend at
uni or just
and even like just the book rich dad
poor dad learning about cash flow
opportunities like 99 of the population
don't know anything about investing for
cash flow or passive income and you
learn that straight away on the course
yeah i really appreciate that and i
think that i mean i put the crash course
out there for free as well yeah and you
can you can
i think you can get it right now online
um on samuel 365
and you can access that for a pound
online right there on the crash course
and then maybe even get the results that
you've got so what's next for you
just uh well refinance this and then
just buy refurb
refinance baby keep flipping and keep
growing
see how big we can make it and i want a
castle as well you've got castles
i'm sure you'll get there laurence i
appreciate you sharing your story it's
massively inspirational thanks for the
shout out about the crash course and
look forward to helping you get to new
heights great i hope so respect matt
great stuff thank you
i hope you enjoyed the interview now
listen listen listen you can either
have excuses right now or you can have
results like lauren's got
i'm going to give you an invitation to
go through the property investors crash
course
the exact thing that lawrence did now
he's financially free from one deal
those flats he's financially free he's
got multiple deals he's got rent to rent
he's got properties in liverpool forget
him forget me this is about you are you
going to make an excuse
or you're going to get results i'm going
to give you an invitation to join the
property investors crash course for a
pound
pay one pound do the crash course
through
samuel 365. become a member do the crash
course one pound
and get results most people watching
this are going to cause an excuse
not right now i'm not sure i left my
card in the living room
don't make an excuse make results i'll
leave a link
in the description get clicked on right
now and i look forward to seeing you on
winners wednesday
real soon one day too peace out click
the link see you there